What’s up guys?
Jared again.
After seeing how anime studio Madhouse knocked
season 2 of Mob Psycho 100 right out of the
park, I, along with most, was pretty stoked
to see what they would do with everyone’s
favorite OP superhero, Saitama.Or as he’s
known in Season 2, Bald Cape.
But somewhere between the middling Episode
1 and where we are now, I came to the conclusion
that One-Punch Man just flat out isn’t delivering
in its second outing.
Sure, the animation quality has taken an unfortunate
hit, but there are still some good fight scenes
and a few laughs as well.
But ultimately, where Season 2 fails is exactly
what made Season 1 such a success: its adherence
to the formal conventions of anime.
Now before you nuke this video to oblivion,
I’m not saying that Season 1 wasn’t a
critique of the shonen genre – it was.
But for all One-Punch Man’s riffing on series
like Dragon Ball Z and Naruto, Season 1 remained
sharp because it still followed a basic shonen
formula.
Season 2, though… not so much.
So join me for this Wisecrack Edition on One-Punch
Man Season 2: What Went Wrong?
And, obviously, spoilers ahead.
Alright guys, a quick recap of what’s going
on with our bald crusader is in order.
Saitama lives in a world populated by heroes
and monsters.
After being royally rejected for an entry
level job, Saitama stumbles upon this deeply
unfortunate-looking child who Sharpied nipples
on this equally unfortunate-looking monster.
Remembering how he once wanted to be a hero,
Saitama decides to protect our ugly youth
and disembowels our crab-based baddie.
Three years of training later and the results
are clear: .
But with all this power comes immense boredom.
Whether it’s training his new disciple,
Genos, or climbing up the ranks of the Hero
Association, or even defeating a world-ending
threat like Boros, Saitama’s sheer strength
saps the fun out of life.
As such, a lot of Saitama’s problems in
the show don’t revolve around getting stronger,
but rather navigating everyday life.
And, this is where One-Punch Man leverages
a lot of its humor.
For example, while every character and their
mom loves to monologue on their novel origin
story, Saitama’s insane strength comes from
a mediocre exercise routine of 100 push-ups,
100 sit ups, 100 squats… you know the drill.
In moments like these, the show parodies the
traditional Shonen trope of heroes and villains
one-upping each other through a constant slew
of new powers, like Goku going Super Saiyan,
or Sasuke gaining the Mangekyou Sharingan,
or, whatever they do in Bleach.
Instead, Saitama’s battles often end in
an anti-climax.
We’re not watching All Might or Deku overcome
their weakness and deliver a devastating finishing
blow.
Instead we’re watching Saitama freak out
midfight about a bargain sale at the local
super market
And, even without a gag, it always ends with
a single punch.
Season 2 largely continues this trend with
a few new plot elements.
Saitama is still climbing the ranks of the
Hero Association, but with the self-proclaimed
hero hunter, Garo, on the loose, Saitama has
entered a martial arts competition to learn
how to defeat him.
Never mind the fact that Saitama does exactly
that here … and here . All the while, a
newly minted Monsters Association is trying
to create a world where their king, Orochi,
reigns supreme, creating absolute chaos in
the process.
So if Season 2 has all the same trappings
of Season 1 along with a new cast of enemies,
what’s actually going wrong here?
To answer that, we’re going to have to look
at what makes the shonen genre tick.
As the history of anime will show, overpowered
protagonists are nothing new.
Just look at the breakout hit this year, That
Time I Got Reincarnated as a Slime, which
focuses on a salary man who dies only to be
reborn in a fantasy world as a super stacked
slime.
Seriously, this thing can absorb any monster
and gain their power, which is the definition
of OP.
But when your hero is already the world’s
strongest, you have yourself a problem.
After all, if your hero can already beat the
big baddie from the get go, then how do you
build conflict?
The answer – for shonen, at least – lies
in a three part formula for plot: pacing +
information + side stories = conflict.
So let’s break that formula down.
Did you ever wonder why it took so many episodes
for Goku to get involved on Planet Namek?
Sure, he was busy training at 100 times Earth’s
gravity so he could take on Frieza, but there’s
another, much simpler reason: to build tension.
See, for our overpowered heroes, there’s
little doubt in the audience’s mind that
they can beat the villain from the start,
but that would make for some very quick and
very boring TV.
As such, shows need a way to delay the hero’s
entry – usually through a combination of
clever pacing and what I like to call asymmetric
information.
Asymmetric Information refers to information
that the audience, and oftentimes other characters,
is privy to, but our main hero is not.
So while Goku conveniently literally spends
19 episodes hurtling through space, blissfully
unaware of what’s happening on Namek, the
audience is slowly growing more anxious as
it watches Krillin and Gohan gather the dragonballs
and brush ever closer to Frieza.
But in delaying your main hero’s arrival,
you’re arguably putting your main plotline
– or your A story in TV-speak – on hold.
As a consequence, shows have to really drum
up their B and C stories – more commonly
known as side plots – in order to compensate.
Basically if your main hero’s not doing
anything, then the rest of the cast needs
to pick up the slack.
In doing so, these B and C stories will keep
help drive the overall narrative forward,
letting the hero swoop in at the last minute
and bring the main plotline to a close.
Keeping with our DBZ example, we spend most
of our time on Namek following two groups:
Gohan, Krillin, and Bulma in one group, and
Vegeta in another.
These two groups make up our B and C plots,
respectively.
Gohan and co. are looking for the Dragon Balls
to revive their dead friends, while simultaneously
trying to save the last of the Namek people
from Frieza’s ruthless slaughter.
Vegeta on the other hand is searching for
the Dragon Balls to receive immortality, thereby
guaranteeing that he can kill Frieza- the
guy who destroyed his planet.
And it’s no coincidence that where these
two plotlines come to a point is also when
Goku arrives.
Under attack by Frieza’s elite mercenary
brigade, the two groups form an uneasy alliance
– agreeing to use one wish to make Vegeta
immortal, and the other two to revive Gohan’s
dead friends.
But just when things couldn’t be any worse
– with the gang beaten half to death and
all 7 Dragon Balls in Frieza’s possession
– who should finally land on Namek but our
hero?
From there, it’s straightforward march right
to Frieza vs. Goku, and the rest is history.
And sure, this one-two punch of pacing and
asymmetric information might seem cheap, but
it’s the bread and butter of animes with
OP characters.
Case in point, Season 1 of One-Punch Man is
a masterclass of this technique.
Regardless of who the baddy is, Saitama’s
only enters the fray at the last moment, usually
as we watch characters like Genos take a beating.
We can see this happening here
and here... andddd here...
But where I think Season 1 pulled this technique
off best is in the Deep Sea King arc.
In it, well, these guys show up: After watching
several A-Class Heroes and even a few S-Class
ones bite the dust, Genos and Saitama decide
to rush to the rescue.
Of course, Genos goes to scout scene first,
leaving Saitama in the dark – which is simultaneously
how the show controls the pacing and creates
the asymmetric information for the arc.
While Saitama wanders around for nearly two
episodes completely clueless, the tension
is left to boil through the rising stakes
of the B and C stories.
First, One-Punch Man sets the stage by letting
us watch the Sea King get increasingly more
powerful in the rain, even beating Speed-o’-Sound
Sonic- ya know, the guy Saitama accidentally
punched in the dick.
The stakes then skyrocket as the Deep Sea
King stumbles upon a whole stadium full of
evacuees, vowing to kill each and every one
of them.
That is, before our B plot arrives in the
form of Genos.
While the two face off in an increasing arms
race of abilities, Genos ultimately loses
when he sacrifices himself to protect an innocent
bystander.
A ball of acid later and Genos is left looking
like this…
As all hope seems lost, though, our C plot
enters the fray – Mumen Rider.
Despite being downright mediocre, the show
painstakingly crafts an arc for this loveable
hero.
The first episode of the Deep Sea King arc
opens with this no-name hero worrying about
Saitama’s recent rise in the ranks
Then, when the threat level gets raised from
Tiger to Demon, it shows Mumen Rider refusing
to run away like all the other C Class heroes.
All of
this leads to an amazing climax, when against
all common sense, Mumen Rider – whose only
ability is that he rides a bicycle – tries
to take on the Deep Sea King himself.
It’s a powerful scene – one that contains
all of One-Punch Man’s love for genre inversions,
right down to that horrible pause when it’s
clear that Mumen Rider isn’t up to the task
But just like when Goku arrives on Namek,
Saitama finally arrives just as the B and
C plots come to a head.
In holding the hero back until the final moment,
the show manages to drive the tension up to
a crisis point, before using our boy, Bald
Cape, to resolve it all with one final punch.
Now, structurally, you might be thinking that
Season 2 has done the same thing, and I’ll
grant you that it does- sometimes.
Let’s look at the season’s main arc, for
example, the Martial Arts Tournament.
In it, Saitama impersonates Silver Fang’s
student, Chiranko, in order to learn what
true martial arts is and take on the Hero
Hunter, Garo.
Of course, the series doesn’t just propel
Saitama to the finals, and we spend most of
the episodes either watching Saitama instant
KO lower ranking opponents, or hear him talk
with his new buddy, Nigamushi.
And sure, the arc ends with a halfway decent
fight scene between Saitama and Suiryu, complete
with a typical One Punch Man inversion – Saitama’s
complete misunderstanding of martial arts.
Given all these similarities, you’d expect
this arc to work, but it doesn’t – and
it all comes back to pacing, information,
and your B and C Stories.
So let’s step back and take a broader view
of this season.
As it turns out, a large part of why this
arc falls so dramatically flat is because
Saitama’s story is not the A plot.
Unlike the Deep Sea King arc, Saitama’s
quest to experience martial arts isn’t what’s
driving the larger story forward.
In fact, outside of the arena, we see a brand
new Monsters’ Association rise up, wreak
all kinds of havoc, and take a hostage – all
with the aim of putting an end to the Hero
Association as we know it.
In this sense, Genos’ and the other heroes’
struggle against this new group forms the
true meat of our larger narrative – our
A plot if you will.
And sure, we’re 100% willing to grant that
this arc employs some clever use of pacing
and asymmetric information in order to keep
Saitama from entering the fray.
After all, because Saitama is locked into
the tournament, he has absolutely no clue
about what’s going on outside the arena,
leaving others characters like Genos to clean
up the mess.
However, Season 2 doesn’t try to connect
Saitama to this larger storyline, in essence
relegating our boy, Bald Cape to the B plot.
In fact, his fight against Suiryu and the
rest of the martial arts nobodies is less
connected to the A Plot than the C Plot – Garo’s
quest to become a monster.
And at least Garo is aware of, and continually
approached by, the Monster’s Association:
.
As a result, instead of watching our side
stories build to a crescendo for our main
storyline, we’re left feeling that our main
hero did nothing.
Sure, Genos is smashed to pieces and things
seem bleak, but for what?
In essence, none of our storylines for the
bulk of Season 2 are working in concert with
one another, creating a fractured narrative
that never truly builds to a climax.
Of course, there is one bright spot in Season
2 that works as a stand-alone arc.
One where the shonen formula is properly deploys,
and where the arc’s specific A, B, and C
plots properly gel – even if the A, B, and
C’s of Season 2 don’t.
I’m talking about the two episodes following
Saitama’s fight with Suiryu.
In it, the Monsters Association barges into
the arena, demanding the martial artists join
their ranks by eating monster cells.
However, Saitama, fearing what the tournament
officials will do after his cover is blown,
has long since escaped.
Instead, for the entirety of the first episode,
the audience watches Suiryu and the other
martial artists fight back against Goketsu,
the very same monster that nearly killed Genos.
Already, we can see the shonen formula in
action.
Controlling the pace via Saitama’s delayed
entry?
Check.
Upping the stakes through asymmetric information?
But we can also see the A, B, and C plots
finally building on one another.
First, we watch the B plot, which focuses
on Suiryu’s growth.
When first introduced to this world class
martial artist, we were pretty much led to
believe that the guy’s a dick.
The only reason he wants to be strong is so
he can coast through life, and his views on
heroes are, well, less than stellar: .
However, as we watch other martial artists
give into the temptation of the Monsters’
Association, Suiryu endears himself to us
by remaining firm.
And with the help of our C Plot – the selfless
arrival of the two heroes Suiryu mercilessly
defeated in tournament, Lightning Max and
Snek, we watch Suiryu gain a new respect for
our heroes.
Of course, the point of the B and C storylines
is to build tension for our main hero and
the A plot, which is exactly what happens
here.
The situation first goes from bad to worse
when Snek and Lightning Max are defeated,
and takes another nosedive when the martial
artists Bakuzan successfully transforms into
a monster, blocking Suiryu’s escape.
Left on the verge of death, Suiryu completes
his arc by finally calling out for
a hero himself.
And of course, this is when our hero, and
the A Plot, finally arrives.
One short punch later and it’s over.
But here’s the thing.
While those two episodes really captured what
made Season 1 so great, it was just too little
too late.
As an audience member, it’s just plain boring
to watch your hero linger on the sidelines
for over half a season, only to have them
briefly occupy the spotlight for two episodes.
While Season 1 regularly built its episodes
with Saitama at its center, always using the
shonen formula to drive tension to a max,
Season 2 largely misses the mark.
And maybe this is intentional.
If there’s one series that’s known for
subverting tropes, it’s One-Punch Man, and
maybe Season 2 amounts to a conscious rejection
of the very Shonen formula that worked so
well in Season 1.
In fact, sometimes it feels like this is downright
the case, like when Saitama finds out all
the monsters retreated 30 minutes before he
arrived on the scene.
But maybe some conventions shouldn’t be
thrown out the window.
With Genos being rushed off to be repaired
and the Hero Association preparing for war,
the A Plot and any role Saitama can play in
it is banished to the background.
Instead, Saitama returns to… well, playing
videogames with King.
Of course, this is part of the joke.
Rather than training for the ultimate battle,
Siatama is getting increasingly frustrated
by losing to King, and only takes a brief
break to defeat the Elder Centipede with a
single punch.
It’s not that this isn’t funny- it is.
It’s that whereas this was once once a show
ABOUT Saitama, it now feels like he’s merely
appended at the end of whatever arc needs
to find completion.
He’s now more of a plot element than a character.
But what do you think, Wisecrack?
Is the main problem with Season 2 the show’s
inability to execute the same Shonen formula
that made Season 1 so great?
Or is it something simpler, like the joke
has simply run on too long?
Maybe we’re tired of all spoofs on the world’s
strongest hero?
Whatever your take, remember to drop us a
line in the comments section and let us know.
Thanks to all our patrons who support the
channel and our podcasts.
Don’t forget to hit that subscribe button,
and as always, peace.